you have more than real housewives
coming out though you are in a movie
yes and you really put on your acting
pants for this I've seen a little bit of
it suspect some male I know wearing a
red shirt
excuse me that as your son Demetrius
Smith where's Dickie it's called never
heard yes tell me about your part how
you got involved why you wanted to be a
part of it okay well I had been talking
to my agent about I mean I want you know
I want to do more acting I want to you
know but I want to do roles where people
don't see candy they don't see just who
I am they want to they really see the
character and so when he brought this
role to me this role is I am the mother
of two sons I'm a single mom in this
movie but a drug drug addicted mom and
my son's you know they don't have their
father in their lives and that's part of
the title have never heard my father
speak and it's just you know how that
affect the family and you know how to
bring that family back together and all
of that it's just you know it's
definitely a story that people really
need to see but as far as me playing
this part I stuff thoroughly enjoyed it
[Music]